hello good morning everybody good
morning youtube how's everybody doing i
have a 2015 silverado
okay chevrolet silverado when the dock
is lost we're going to go ahead and
remove
the ignition lock cylinder get the key
cool from there
we're going to use our keto our keto max
and our dolphin to cut out the key code
and we're going to use our auto pro pad
to program the key
okay make sure you subscribe hit like
right now go ahead
if you guys are liking this video so far
all right guys so the first thing we're
gonna do is remove this plastic okay
there's no screws holding it all you
gotta do is just pull it off
and it should come off okay
i'm gonna go ahead and remove it and
then get back to you okay
okay so this plastic comes off from the
top there's no screws on it holding it
down
and now we're left with the ignition
lock cylinder housing
as you guys can see there's a little
hole up here
that's the hole we're gonna use to
maneuver to take this out
okay to pull this out now the way this
toe goes in
okay
this is the side that it goes in okay
this little stick is facing that way
like a scorpion
and then it goes in and you're gonna
push it down maybe like an inch or two
and try to turn it around okay
so as you guys can see we turn that
around we turn the scorpion around
okay now this is the tricky part we're
gonna have to feel where the little lock
is at and at the same time
we're gonna go ahead and pull this out
okay
so just fill the little lockers out do
it
pull it your way this way okay like if
the scorpion's attacking you
and we're gonna pull this out okay
so as you guys can see i already
i'm already able to pull it out okay
so just make sure that you guys take it
out slowly
okay now the pink coat you guys
the pink coat is not gonna be on this
part it's actually inside there
so you have to use this piece to take it
out okay so all you got to do is just
put it in there turn it to the on
position
okay
show you guys you stick it in there
you turn it to the on position with the
end
okay
now while it's in the on position we're
gonna get this little piece of metal
and as you guys can see there's that
little plastic top we're going to put
this
right here
[Music]
so it pushes that little plastic tub up
okay you have a little tab
as you guys can see it's holding it up
so it lets you pull out or you can use a
little screwdriver to hold that up
while you're pulling it out and that
easily comes out okay so that has a key
coat on there
not this okay just be careful with this
part because this part will fly out
that's spring loaded all right
so as you guys can see i have a little
tail piece in here and the kiko's
variant on here
okay as you guys can see that's that's
the keycard right there
you can't really see it but it's in
little dots
okay so that's going to be the key code
all right you guys so if you guys don't
know what key code it is um i recommend
you guys get this book
it's the it's called the auto truck
keyblank reference by elko
all right and as you guys can see we
have our our model right there silverado
2015 as you guys can see the series the
chord series starts with a v
so you're going to find the letter v and
four digits okay
and you guys can see it uses it tells
you what k uses
v119 pt tells you the service key it
tells you what programmers you can
program it with okay
all right you guys so we got our key
code now we're going to go to our max q2
and our dolphin
make sure you connect the first via
bluetooth
go ahead and click on it as you guys can
see i'm disconnected and i'm connecting
now as you guys can see i'm on wi-fi so
you guys are going to enter it for this
then we're going to go to all keys lost
we're going to look for chevrolet we're
going to click on that
and you guys can see a picture of how
the key code is supposed to be
starts with a letter z and has four
numbers in it
okay depending on what vehicles you have
the first letter is gonna be different
so it's it's calculated right now
and as you guys can see it tells us to
go to use clamp m2
on side a okay stop at the tip put a new
key in there
here's our cut for our vehicle then
we're going to go to cut key
and we're going to continue okay
okay
[Music]
after we're done cutting it we can go
ahead and program into the vehicle
[Music]
do
okay so if you guys want to put this
back together um you got to make sure
you attach the top piece to it first
okay like so
also when you guys are putting in the
the ignition lock cylinder
you guys got to make sure that the
ignition switch is on
okay and put the whole thing together
okay so when you guys are putting the
switch back on make sure that you put
the key in there
and you turn this little piece okay that
this little piece
aligns with that little piece okay so
that it got going smoothly
as you guys can see
and i went in smoothly as you guys can
see
okay so just make sure you align those
two and put the tail piece in or it's
not going to go in smooth okay
as long as you have you have this thing
aligned
it'll go in small like butter
and then we could just put our cover
back on okay
okay guys so we have our ignition switch
we have our key return we have our
ignition
switch on we're gonna go to
usgm we're gonna agree
okay we're going to go to resecurity
code okay because
we need to read the security code on
this newer chevy's we're going to go to
bcm
read pin code as
it says scan 2 is going to red pin do
you want to continue yes
so right now it's going to read the pin
that we need so in order to program a
key
or do anything you need to read the pins
first okay
so it's right in the pan just bear with
it
it's communicating give it a minute
you guys have any questions you know in
the comment section below
okay so as you guys can see
there's our pin right there 7960 okay
we're gonna press okay that's our bin
whether to generate a pdf report no
okay we're gonna go back
we're gonna go back we're gonna go to
immobilizer we're gonna go by vehicle
and then we're gonna go to chevrolet and
then we're gonna go to usa
and we're gonna look for our model
okay silverado we're gonna go to 2012
2016.
okay so we're going to go to program
keys without smart because this is not
smart okay it's a regular key we're
going to go to our keys lost
close outdoors switching listen to on
position press this to continue
security code 7960
okay we're gonna press okay
it's communicating now it's telling us
to wait 10 minutes okay
so go ahead and wait 10 minutes until
the timer's over
okay
okay so it's configuring the system now
first open then close driver door next
confirm
all electric electrical components is
off then press ok
we're gonna open the door
close the door okay make sure
everything's off lights are off
radio's off
okay everything looks off i guess we're
gonna press okay
please insert the key you wish to
program and switch ignition to on then
press ok
we're going to enter the key i want to
program switching listen to on
and then we're going to press ok
configure system you want to program
another key we're going to press no
switch ignition to off and remove the
key
then press ok
okay so let's configure the system told
me to wait 48 seconds
we're waiting
switching mission to on position then
press okay
i'm gonna press okay
as you guys can see the mobilizer light
turned off already
which is a good sign now we're gonna
press okay
program is complete let's go ahead and
turn on the truck make sure that it
starts
perfect truck starts
immobilizer light turns off
okay guys we're gonna program your
remotes okay we're gonna program a new
remote
make sure you have all your emotes with
you when you're doing this we're gonna
go to usgm
we're gonna agree
okay we're gonna go to remote
we're gonna go to usa we're gonna go to
auto
auto detection is communicating ignition
switch is on he's in the ignition that
dinging is letting us know that
that the key is in the ignition okay
can't type four
max numbers or remote are allowed start
in memory okay
so everything's gonna be erased make
sure you have all your most with you
as you guys can see it says remote key
learning active active
hold lock and unlock
for eight seconds each
okay then we're going to press other one
[Music]
not gonna unlock
let's close this
make sure they work perfect
okay both work so just make sure you
have both remotes with you okay
okay if you guys want to add a second
key to the vehicle just go ahead and put
the
put the program key okay inside
wait until that lock turns off
okay we're going to take out the the
first pro we're going to take out the
prong kit and put the new key in
right away and watch that lock turn off
like magic perfect so we successfully
programmed
we successfully programmed the new key
okay without a programmer
go ahead and try it on turn it on again
perfect so that's how you program a
second key
without a programmer okay so you put in
the first program
key turn it on wait until lock turns off
take off the program key put in the new
key
turn it on right away make sure you
don't last more than 10 seconds doing
that
and wait until that lock turns off as
soon as the light turns off your key has
been magically programmed okay
that's a good tip for you guys